alors ça faisait longtemps que j'avais
pas faire un petit faq qui te réponses
aux questions on se détend let's go
c'est quand ta prochaine facture bah
maintenant pourquoi envisages-tu pas la
chirurgie maintenant que tu es riche
c'est quoi une goutte a raison je vais
me faire affaire le visage tu as couché
avec combien de femmes 2000 quelle est
ta position préférée c'est un peu osé
comme réponse mais moi le bien être
assis voilà j'aime bien d'acheter à si
je joue bien je voudrais avoir un autre
animal domestique alors en ce moment je
réfléchis éventuellement à posséder un
aigle c'est un projet je voulais être le
maître ici quand est ce que tu as des
muscles alors j'aurai des muscles le 5
janvier 1 c'est prévu c'est planifié son
planning
c'est écrit le 5 janvier j'ai des
muscles sera tué la vidéo city paris oui
tu te filme avec quelle caméra c'est
vraiment la voie du mec il parle comme
ça dans la vie alors voici un petit
miroir pour vous puissiez voir la caméra
avec laquelle je me filme à l'école
j'étais plutôt le leader ou la victime à
l'époque je faisais pas être question tu
vois moi j'avais une philosophie de on
est tous et même on est tous égaux en
s'entraident mutuellement et après je me
fait racketter un sas et après faire
plutôt beauté batterie on veut faire un
tuto orthographe 1 ça peut être plus
utile pour toi peux-tu dire quelque
chose en ch'ti alors attention tous les
gens qui me trouvais classe le cas
présent c'est à dire personne bah vous
allez être déçus ferme de bouc tanner
vaccarezza un latin capio à latter
cochettes et permettent dif
ça veut dire enlève ton chapeau enlève
tes chaussettes et ferme ta gueule voilà
c'est un truc que tu dis rarement dans
la vie quand tes fans te reconnaissent
dans la rue
qu'est ce qu'ils te disent tout le temps
en premier bah c'est vrai que souvent
leur crème anglaise dans la rue une
10h50 et vidéo tu fais un peu fragile
est ou non en vrai plus homs est plus
viril tout ça et c'est faux c'est
complètement faux et dit jamais ça on
vient de personnes te reconnaissent par
jour en moyenne 0
quand je serai chez moi tu a déménagé ou
si le décor qui a changé est ben oui
j'ai déménagé plusieurs fois et je suis
maintenant ici dans cet appartement qui
n'est pas un décor assez montré à part
comme le prouve par exemple ces haricots
verts ou c'est énorme 4 salut j'adore ce
que tu fais comment est la relation avec
ton père et toi tu as raison que ce mec
va être mon psy
ouais mon père n'a toujours été proche
lorsqu'il rentrait le soir et une fois
été avec sa ceinture c'était des moments
de souffrance et en même temps de joie
tu me croit quand je te dis que je suis
batman
non un conseil pour être musclé donne un
conseil pour être musclé c'est de ne pas
suivre mes conseils comme tu peux le
voir sur sur mon corps ça a été un échec
il était comment ce poulet de deux
semaines peut tirer wine pour ceux qui
n'ont pas vécu cette nappe story aux
formes j'ai complètement oublié un
poulet dans ce four pendant près de deux
semaines
donc là ça sent vraiment le cadavre
est ce que tu pourrais m'inviter à ton
show mais genre gratuitement merci c'est
quoi océane carrément je te mets deux
places avec qui tu veux dans la ville de
ton choix pour venir voir mon spectacle
c'est cadeau tu arrives à garder un peu
de vie privée ben oui regarde difficile
comme ça l'aïe un petit peu aussi là
comme ça et puis toi les jambes hâlées
évidemment le défi je m'y attendais je
m'épile les jambes
rightnow
abbas est absolument inutile j'ai déjà
aucun poil sur les jambes a pu teint un
peu quand même hein ça mais j'arrête
j'arrête cette activité qu'as-tu ramené
du québec
alors petit souvenir jarre née cette
petite fille est en forme de sirop
d'érable
ça ne veut rien dire d'ailleurs en forme
de feuille d'érable élisant qui est en
train de se parler de parler c c'est
horrible pc gc ca ensuite on voit ça on
a besoin battu faire une vidéo avec les
angles alors ça non hors de question à
l'automne prochain
tu as aimé ton expérience au québec j'ai
adoré le québec j'adorais les québécois
par contre appeler un happy meal joyeux
festin c'est pas possible ou alors pulp
fiction fiction pulpeuse inexplicable
fixe loupé un stage à vous mes amis mais
pour moi c'est non le message est passé
et nous qui a raison c'est lui qui a
raison
ouais ça c'est bien c'est pas mal déjà
on sent que vous avez bien raison là
parce que tu peux nous faire l'accent
français
[ __ ] c'est quoi ces démarrages [ __ ]
jetteront sans quoi paris c'est trop de
la merde
en plus on n'a même pas nous fixe us je
sais à pop alors d'aller faire du
shopping et la meuf elle m'a saoulé quoi
trop relou sérieux c'est très nul ne
peut pas passer mon tour je t'envoie
c'est parti pour une mutation
tabarnak merci à tous je manque
allègement contre chris mangent de la
merde comme tu dis genre manger de la
merde c'est ça ton mois avant
tu vois mangent de la merde je te
remercie à bientôt c'est quoi
attends mange de la marde je m'en contre
calais ce que tu penses manquerait ce
qu'est ce que tu peux compter sur
netflix os manta marde québécois tous
les insultes c'est des trucs d'église je
m'en contre carlos je manquerais ce jeu
man band metz austin marque cierges de
curé porte d'aiguelèze gratter drame ça
n'a aucun sens merci lysandre pour sur
l'intervention et à très très bientôt
entre bien chez toi que tu fais là
merci à tous d'avoir suivi cet effet
yoyo merci pour vos questions à très
bientôt pour une prochaine vidéo avec un
minimum de poils sur les jambes restés
les mêmes
ciao seattle chicago pittsburgh
j'aimerais tellement un jour dire à
quelqu'un juste pour le style à deux
mains demain je peux pas j'ai un truc à
faire à washington
paris c'est trop pour av je pense que si